the 45 year old allegedly raped and
abused 91 children over a 15-year period
while he was a child care worker
recording what happened and sharing the
content online he's been charged in
court in Brisbane this is going on right
around the country it's the reason we
had a royal commission and it's the
reason the Royal commission came up with
the recommendations it did there are a
lot of offenders out there doing this to
Children child abuse offenses the arrest
was the result of an international
police operation the rapid expansion of
social media platforms such as Tick Tock
Snapchat and Facebook is increasingly
helping offenders share and access
illegal material
what we're dealing with is a phenomenal
amount of content that our for mostly
our victim identification teams globally
are trying to find the victims in
we're doing our best you know law
enforcement is absolutely doing its best
but the the production the content fire
outstrips the actual human resources
that police can throw at it the internet
is
material were recorded last year by the
national Center for missing and
exploited children in the United States
live streaming Technologies better
webcams and smartphones have changed the
way offenders approach their victims
it's almost Unthinkable how much
material is actually out there so that
rate is actually growing on an annual
basis and it will continue to grow and
less tech companies sort of do a lot
more to actually stop that
authorities globally are making some
progress installing and identifying the
spread of images of child sexual abuse
but the dark web is making it even more
difficult for law enforcement
organizations with offenders able to
operate anonymously online
it's here where offenders collaborate
and share techniques on how to engage
and groom their victims where you have
chat forums with thousands and thousands
of offenders teach each other how to
offend and how to approach Children
online
I would speculate that absolutely it is
having an impact on the rates of online
grooming of children
it's a battle not lost but one that
police acknowledge will continue to
evolve
Sarah Clarke Al Jazeera Brisbane